you helped a lot of people as a doctor
as an educator
live better lives live longer
but you yourself are a mortal being
do you think about your own mortality do
you think about your death are you
afraid of death oh yeah um
i'm not i've faced it
been close
yourself yeah
yeah
how do you think about it what wisdom do
you gain from having come close to death
oh the fact that the whole thing ends
it's liberating
it's very liberating i mean i'm serious
i i was close
and not too long ago
um
and uh
it was a sense of
you know
this may be the way it ends
and
[Music]
i've done my best
it's not been perfect
and if it ends here it ends here the
people around me are trying to do their
best
and in fact uh i got pulled out of it
but it didn't look like i was going to
get pulled out of it
are you ultimately grateful
for the ride
even though it ends well it's a
little hot um
i think so
if i know
you know you can't take the ride if you
know what the it's going to end well
it's not the real ride it's just a ride
um
but i
haven't gone through the whole thing i
definitely freed me of a sense of
anxiety about death
and it
said to me do you best every day
cause it's gonna end sometime
you